the future is our kids so they will
define what it will be I just want them
to know that it will not be all it's
it's just a matter of changing the way
we are thinking there is electricity
everywhere ok anyhow as an electricity
plant and no one as a gas station his
home my father add an electric car it
was not a performance car at all it was
just a car which is not put it in at all
it was a way for him to improve the way
he's using energy my next car will be an
electric one that I need to find a car
that I can use in my life every day I
didn't want to buy an i bred car I want
to full electric car because I believe
in it as my parents show me that it's
possible
when I go to Tesla I was able to say
okay I am part of the electric movement
as a Tesla oh no I can't be involved in
this and make the change happen I was
looking for a job that can help to bring
more ease ease on the market we have one
project which is working on the
electrifying at school bus kids when I
went to schools if they go to schools
with an electric vehicle
it's put in their mind that okay
electric mobility is possible okay we it
worked
my son is a 11 year old now they're
asking me okay where do we start the car
what are the option and they are playing
with the screen on the car their
interest is inside the Tesla it's
already inside them that having an old
car is not an option they know that
their car will be electric the first
cars I want to drive will be electric
I'm very proud of that I'm Stefan to
schedule and this light is powerful life
since 2013